This has been my new favorite late night snack lately.
Let me show you what I do.
I grab a bowl, I add some sliced up strawberries to it.
Also add some whole milk to it.
You can use whatever milk you want.
I like to add quite a lot.
And then sometimes I like to add just a little bit of sugar to it.
But you can leave this out.
Some nights I do. I sprinkle that on top.
This is the perfect sweet treat.
It tastes so good.
There's something about the combination of strawberries and milk.
Divine. This is what we're working with.
Used to have this all the time when I was small.
It's basically just strawberries and milk,
but this combination is so good.
It reminds me of strawberries and cream,
which I also really like having.
But there's something so simple about the milk with the strawberry